mmm welcome to this video my computer
was acting a bit strangely this is why I
had a slight delay at the start of the
video okay we gotta tell Kanye playing
white against PVC okay the 97 lon hmm
y'all know g5 is the most testing move
it seems but then I really don't know
much about it I think this is the way it
is played on this right Knight f3 is
Rudra ok and now we're back on track I
think and night before
yeah maybe I don't really I don't really
know it too too well okay is this
disperse this disposition from Chomsky
again scalp off like wake up late King
e7 threatening g5 and maybe
it's a funny idea maybe this is exactly
it exactly this position but I'm not
quite sure king is seven this
threatening g5 okay g5 tweenage 3g for
winning a piece whoo okay this didn't
happen so I'll just continue to develop
like very often does not castle in this
opening or castling long b6 Bishop e7
long castle in short i just take age six
and two and edwin probably okay the
question is do I have do I have some
better move than rookie on rookie one
and 95 looks very logical but he will
play c5 this is this much is clear yeah
it still looks like the way to go 95
c-5m then it's not so clear what I
should should do then yeah well he's
threatening g5 probably yeah come on
hard to play without the smooth c5 what
should I play on c5
yeah I cannot really take Bishop takes
d5 okay I'll try to get this bishop if
he takes d4 take d 6 and then Bishop a
phone claiming for compensation with the
bishops and the dark squares many
interesting lines now you can think
about g5 Queen h3s what I need to play
then it's not exactly ideal
but you can certainly just take defaults
not not bad what I'm wondering is if I
just read capture can he probably take a
check so I'm as intended i should take
here and play for compensation on the
dark square Bishop I for this was the
the key idea that this Bishop is very
nicely placed on f4 or controlling the
other way to be eight so that his King
has no easy place on my be aight here i
thought i thought rookie five might be a
might be possible here kara a to hanks
but still hmm
the problem is my queen is a little bit
off and he's threatening g5 now
mmm g5 is prom okay I cannot protect hm
there's no no time for such luxuries who
came is threatening this chick
yeah cannot take here which is really
unfortunate
I don't really see a good move here
we're taking g7 but it's not really
satisfactory you can easily just take
the beat to pawn don't think I'm it's
really a problem
hmm
huh sure it's not exactly ugh but it's
it's enough I don't really have a good
move hmm yeah Jack's g5 threat was a big
problem I really think I had to have
enough composition at the beginning but
it very quickly fizzled out due to my
off-site Queen Queen needed to be on the
queenside to to do something against the
king considering that this Bishop only
five is nicely placed yeah
check 29 seconds I'm pretty sure he had
better and better ways to play then what
he did but it's probably still perfectly
enough
sure I need to be quick here
now you can just take it but he's taking
ages check check time morning what is
this maturity wise I'm a pawn down black
for effects audience really slow I
didn't really I didn't really pay much
attention to the clock time yeah jab it
was just bad i mean he was for some
reason taking him i'm a minute down and
i'm lost completely but i'm still
curious I don't really think this should
be so terrible let's see maybe it is due
to the month due to the bed queen on h4
chan my queen is so off side and this
threat is some chap it's not really
great I mean I need to do something else
here maybe I'm misjudging this but this
is just a very yeah 95 it's not a good
move probably this is just a liability
but there's this threat unfortunately if
I do nothing move oops no pic g5 between
here g fo and that's it f it's um the
spawn is simply surviving connected with
this move mm yeah the compounds to play
that Jeff maybe maybe something like
this is necessary but this does not
really make my opening play look too
great yeah I'm not not an expert
probably there's something something to
be improved earlier alright thanks for
watching